we got big news tonight the GOP debates
in New Hampshire have been canceled
Nikki Haley is refusing to debate unless
Donald Trump is there Ronda Santa says
he will debate two empty podiums and
they were like yeah okay no Ron thanks
for the offer but uh Nikki Haley did the
meme and so uh this is one of the
funniest things she's ever done she
basically declares or she literally
declares that the result in Iowa prove
it's now a two-person race but she came
in third place so I guess she's uh in
some way conceding to Ronda C this I I
guess but I I think the reality here is
the establishment play is that the GOP
Primary is the actual election Nikki
Haley is a Democrat she is funded by
democrats Democrats are voting for her
and I think they're hoping that in
places like New York City and California
and Illinois when they have their
Republican primaries Democrats show out
in force for Nikki Haley and then it
doesn't matter if Joe Biden is running
for the Democratic ticket because if
it's Biden versus Haley you get a
Democrat either way